Welcome to the program. Voting is happening
now and it's happening early in record
numbers. We've talked about it on the bonus show.
We are going to do a deeper dove into these early
votes next week. But I want to talk about voter
fraud for a moment. I'm sure, you know, if you've
been watching the show, we're paying attention to
either left or right wing media because, frankly,
it's been a story on both, although we're with
different angles. Republicans have been going on
and on and on about in-person voter fraud
for years. And almost every actual case of
in-person voter fraud has been Republicans.
We had the situation out of North Carolina.
We've had Republicans supposedly supposedly trying
to test the system and getting caught committing
voter fraud. That's in-person. We now have a Q
and non aligned mail carrier court for allegedly
hoarding and throwing out bags of mail. Donald
Trump claims that the Postal Service can't handle
mail in ballots, but of course it can. And then
incomes a pro trump queue and on mail carrier
and gets caught allegedly making the mail not
work. Special agents reportedly raided the home
of a mail carrier in Baldwin, Pennsylvania, over
the weekend because they got a tip from neighbors
that there were bags full of undelivered mail
being thrown into the trash. And according to
the Pittsburgh City Paper, that individual is Sean
Troche. His social media profiles are filled with
all sorts of extreme right wing Q And on related
references to, say, tannic pedophile Meems,
which alleged that the media is covering up child
sex trafficking. It relates to pizza, Gayed and
all sorts of other nonsense. Also, his social
media profiles refer to the tyranny of corona
virus quarantines and lockdowns. And as we know,
that perception of a tyrannical quarantines
recently led to a plot to kidnap the Michigan
governor, Gretchen Whitmer. So this stuff has
real consequences. According to KDKA, neighbors
reported that Postal Service ACIA agents raided
the home of this mail carrier and confiscated
eight large garbage bags of suspected undelivered
mail that this mail carrier reported reportedly
put on the curb to be picked up with the week's
garbage. A statement from the USPS office
of the inspector general says that, quote,
Special agents recovered several different
classes of mail, including business mail, flats
and small amount of first class mail. We expect
to perform a piece count of the mail tomorrow and
make arrangements to have the mail delivered to
customers as soon as feasible now. Importantly, I
guess no particular mention of whether there were
absentee ballots in the mail one way or the other,
although they may not identify the absentee
ballots by any in any way other than by the
class of mail that they represent. We just
don't know whether there are absentee ballots
found in the bags of trash. Neighbors believe that
Troche has trashed undelivered mail in the past.
No charges has as of yet have as of yet been
filed. And this is mirroring the entire in-person
voter fraud ruse perfectly. Republicans have been
complaining about in-person voter fraud and rigged
elections for through mail in ballots this year.
And you've got a Q and on guy caught allegedly
hoarding and dumping mail, much like they've
been talking about the in-person voter fraud
for a long time. And almost everybody who gets
caught is is a right winger. And then you've got
Trump's postmaster putting in place orders and
guidelines to prevent the timely delivery of
mail across the country. We've seen California
Republicans deploy these fake decoy ballot boxes.
We've seen Republican governors and secretaries of
state blocking early voting, purging voter rolls.
It's then we even saw after the 2016 election,
Republicans in the Senate, including the Senate
majority leader, Mitch McConnell, not
even bringing to the floor for debate
bills to deal specifically with election
interference, including from foreign countries,
but even domestic interference as well. And
on and on and on. So almost without exception,
the rigging and the tampering with absentee
voting has been from people on the right. It is
projection. It's undeniable. Yes, it's stunning.
But at this point, is it even really surprising?
And what do Republican senators think about this
guy caught hoarding and trashing mail? This is the
real election fraud and it should be prosecuted.
They seem to have made the decision. Maybe they
made it a. Illicitly, it doesn't have to be
an explicit decision where they sit around and
they say if we don't do this stuff, we will lose.
But they seem to have recognized that they have a
much better shot at winning and may maybe their
only shot at winning is if they try to cheat.
And it's not just the right screaming
mail fraud when there isn't any.
It's the right screaming mail fraud when they
are the ones doing the mail fraud. Of course,
this instance, as far as we know, was not
coordinated by the Republican Party. But again,
what they tell us we need to be worried about
because of the left. We really have to be
worried about it because of the right. That's the
reality. And we will continue to track whether
charges are filed. And, of course, they should
be and whether there are more instances of this.